is this right you and Jen Aniston are in
a film together well my wife and I are
writing a movie Jennifer is playing the
first female praise can we edit that out
no that that takes money we don't have
I'll give you some of my travel later
cash all right
go edit it out Jennifer Aniston is
playing the first female president of
the United States of America start so
far and then I am the first lady oh cool
yeah I didn't get an applause break well
no we have it there's a church group in
the audience
not so sure about that yeah that is a
very cool idea so Jennifer Anniston is
the president you're the first lady
where did you get the idea well my
wife's really into politics and when we
first got together I said you should run
for mayor and then a beat later I
thought how it would make me the first
lady and I thought that's good I'll do
it and Wow you got a real fire in your
belly and then as the as time went on
and we joked about it more it became Oh
what if he ran for president then I
would be the first lady of the entire
country
yeah and then we just couldn't stop
joking around about it and then I was
like I think this actually might be a
really good movie idea and so we've
reached out to Jennifer Aniston and she
truly and I'm sorry if I don't know if
here's the thing she signed on
immediately we didn't have a story at
all
we were just like you're the president
and I'm first lady and she was like
where do I sign that's incredible that's
fantastic yeah and then we'll ferrell
was like what i went in on this and we
were like okay so now Will Ferrell's in
the movie we had there's not even a so
we haven't written anything
and we just we went out we sold it
everybody I want it we're like okay
you act like someone's just backed into
your car this is good this is a gun it's
great everybody has told us like don't
get used to this you know this is not
how it usually goes know people have
years and years and years of
disappointment of course and you just
pitch one thing and everyone's on board
yeah and it's like you know I kind of
Jennifer Aniston's very attractive yes
she is
yeah yeah and I just was like hey how
about we're married yeah she's also very
funny and it's been a real joy to to
write for her have you you spent time
with her now she's she's a very nice
person oh yeah yeah she's so nice you
clearly know her better than I do
no I do
you